des centaines d'interprètes afghan td
l'armée canadienne dans des missions
souvent dangereuses
au bail rationnelle afghanistan aux
côtés des troupes canadiennes en 2009 il
a servi comme interprète
des missions auprès des troupes
d'infanterie des missions sur l'ensemble
du territoire avec la mort en embuscade
dans le convoi les deux premiers
véhicules militaires ont réussi à passer
le pont mais pour le troisième il a
explosé
à son bord il y avait quatre soldats 200
morts
malgré la peur il a continué à servir
l'armée canadienne mais avec le retour
des talibans au bayer chakib nasa me
n'avait plus le choix que de partir
il a connu le règne de la terreur des
talibans et ne crois pas qu'ils aient
changé la chute rapide de kaboul ne lui
a laissé que peu de temps pour fuir
au bailleur chapier bas mis deux jours
pour parcourir les quelques kilomètres
qui le séparait de l'aéroport les
talibans bloquaient déjà les accès à
coups de rafales de mitraillettes et
à chaque coup de feu mon fils pleurait
j'ai perdu tous mes moyens greyhound
spar et la faim au ventre la soif son
fils dans un bras et trois valises à
traîner au bayer chakib se demande
encore comment il a pu y arriver
il dit que l'avenir de ses enfants est
assuré lui qui a toujours été fier de
travailler pour le canada il espère
maintenant y travailler
hayat radio canada montréal